quel est votre plus grand regret à ce
stade de la campagne la candidature
d'Éric Zemmour et leur aliment de votre
nièce mario marachal c'est fini ça
c'était avant le avant le premier tour
familiale en pleine campagne c'est
violent c'est vrai c'est difficile mais
il faut être capable encore une fois
d'oublier ses sentiments personnels pour
penser à la mission qu'on s'est donné
qui est une mission de protection donc
moi le regret que j'ai en ce second tour
si vous voulez c'est la brutalité
d'Emmanuel Macron je trouve très violent
très brutal à mon égard très agressif
parfois même injurieux et c'est pas
utile voilà donc ça c'est un regret
parce qu'on aurait pu faire un second
tour sur un second tour de bon niveau de
de haut niveau qu'un président sortant
alors on va pas rentrer en politique
moi je suis dans une ambiance parfaite
non mais je te le dis
c'était les deux mêmes interviews donc
au timing prêt à la seconde près ils ont
duré 10 minutes c'était les mêmes
questions qui étaient posées quasiment
Marine Le Pen et manuel Macron ils ont
répondu de manière très différente
Emmanuel Macron il a fait des rêves
et c'est plus livré d'accord on va
regarder puisque j'ai pas vu ça mais
j'ai rien vu moi je te dis la vérité moi
je suis arrivé moi j'étais
tranquillement en train d'aller au Parc
des Princes j'ai rencontré un mec et que
sa sœur
en train de regarder un mec en train de
galoche sa sœur qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette famille
quel est votre plus grand regret à ce
stade de la campagne de ne pas être
descendu plus tôt dans la mairie d'avoir
sous-estimé peut-être la dynamique de
votre adversaire je n'ai pas de regrets
là aussi c'est pas comme ça non parce
que vous savez j'ai fait campagne autant
que j'ai pu et j'ai présidé autant que
j'ai dû voilà il y a à peine de moi on
avait encore une épidémie de covid qui
était à un niveau très aigu qui
inquiétait qui supposait des décisions
il y a six semaines
les bombes tombées sur Kiev a commencé
de tomber sur Kiev la guerre était
déclarée et donc il était normal à ce
moment-là que je sois très engagé sur
les questions internationales pour à la
fois essayer d'abord de prévenir puis
agir et protéger les Françaises et les
Français de tout escalade de la guerre
et de tenir la position de la France
donc c'est normal
oui moi j'ai pas aimé
j'ai pas aimé parce que d'abord je
trouve que en terme de timing ça arrive
bien trop tard dans l'entre-deux-tours
des portraits un peu intimistes
faussement intimiste d'ailleurs qui ne
sont que de la com ça n'apportait rien
moi j'aurais préféré que on fasse
programme contre programme avec par
exemple qu'on aille plus dans le fond
donc les portraits moi je les ai trouvés
c'était un coup d'épée dans l'eau ils
ont servi à rien parlent entre eux
d'ailleurs
je vous dis un truc sur mercredi voilà
oui madame je suis pas d'accord je suis
pas d'accord elle a essayé dans les
questions d'avoir un peu de perso le
regret Emmanuel Macron qui parle de sa
grand-mère moi j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait
des trucs qui sortaient de ce qu'on
entendait d'habitude et donc ils
viennent tard mais avec une originalité
on est dans l'entre-deux-tours alors les
portraits sur la grand-mère ou sur je
sais pas quoi ou sur la brutalité c'est
c'était pas c'était plus le lieu
maintenant et il faut aller sur le son
des programmes pour savoir pour qui on
va aller voter mais pas sur on aime on
n'aime pas il est gentil ou elle est
méchante ou tout cela c'est plus là
[Rires]
c'est bon ça va oui madame
elle a l'air chez ça c'est sûr il y a
pas de souci mais le problème c'est
qu'on n'attend pas ça de 7 à 8 moi
normalement ce moment-là de l'interview
j'ai la petite musique d'ailleurs ils
ont laissé alors moi j'adore cette
émission mais quand tu te retrouves sur
le portrait de 7 à 8 frère c'est qui ou
pas
la musique la musique trouver la moi la
musique là tu entends la musique ça va
pas dans ta chambre
tu peux pas arriver et dire ouais je
reviens du parking
[Musique]
sont comme ça
avec la
c'était forcément les mains malheur quoi
[Musique]
de musique
[Rires]
cette musique claire tu as gagné regarde
je n'ai rien on va retrouver Jean-Louis
non mais ta gueule
ce soir 7 à 8 c'est intéressé à
Jean-Louis froussard qui a gagné plus de
250 millions à l'Euro Millions
[Rires]
c'est quoi il faut mettre combien
d'argent
[Rires]
et vous allez mettre la musique avec
tous les têtes des gens de la résine
parce qu'ils sont finies
c'est terminé pour moi
le portrait de cette année c'est un
marqueur du programme
même si demain ils ont un pressing le 5
à 7 je regarde mais le truc c'est que
voilà aujourd'hui excuse-moi papa dans
ta barbe
dans la barre merci s'il te plaît on est
enrichi là on va voir la tête de tous
ceux qui avaient voilà allez merci allez
mettez-moi la musique
je veux voir les visages
de ces gens qu'on ne reverra plus
[Applaudissements]
je vais les voir
voilà
un ami
mon ordin